it is interesting because also as these
talks happen and the normalization of
Kim happens some of that pressure the US
has asserted comes off because now
you're not necessarily on the bad list
of the United States if you're doing
business with Kim Jong and look what
we're doing right now and I know Ben
Tracy our correspondent here in central
Illinois has spent so much time on the
ground in North Korea and knows this
issue well well Margaret you know there
was speculation today that Kim Jong hoon
might go visit a factory that he might
visit a local school here where there
are classrooms named after his father
and grandfather but he didn't do any of
that he basically stayed in his hotel
all day and it looks like he was really
preparing for these meetings with
President Trump North Korean state media
took this unusual step of releasing this
photo of Kim Jong hoon they say this is
him getting briefed by his top advisors
now North Korean state media says that
he was receiving a detailed report about
the meetings the US and North Korean
delegations had in preparation for the
summit of course the big question is
whether Kim jong-un has come here to
actually agree to take the first steps
towards giving up his nuclear weapons
and if he is what does he want in return
the North Koreans desperately want
relief from sanctions that are crippling
their economy they're also interested in
a formal declaration that would end the
Korean War that is something they see as
an important security guarantee but also
perhaps a way to eventually argue that
the United States should remove 28,500
US troops that are stationed in South
Korea now without really having to give
up much of anything yet Kim jong-un has
already gotten two big things that he
wants he is getting this second summit
with President Trump that gives him even
more legitimacy on the world stage as
this
respected leader he's also getting time
President Trump has basically said he's
no longer in a rush and that he's not
going to pressure North Korea to quickly
denuclearize Margaret
and thank you